he made the playoffs with the 49ers last
year played in his super bowl with them
and now he hopes to take the saints back
to the super bowl along with the rest of
that team
fresh off of their season-ending win
against carolina getting set for
the chicago bears in the middle game of
the sunday wild card triple header he is
emmanuel sanders how are you emmanuel
i'm good rich how are you better for
talking to you what what does this mean
to be back in the playoffs for the new
team
with this season i mean it means a lot
you know throughout my journey it's 11
year journey
you know i i entered the league uh with
the pittsburgh shows went to the super
bowl
then had like three years where we
didn't make the playoffs go to denver
make the playoffs there uh win the super
bowl in the second year he didn't have
like two or three years and no playoffs
and then
last year going to super bowl again and
now this year back in the playoffs with
the opportunity to go to super bowl so
to ride the roller coaster the ups and
downs and
and the flow of just the nfl career uh
to be back in the playoffs and
and being not in the playoffs before you
know
like these don't it doesn't happen like
this all the time
and to be on the super bowl caliber team
with the super bowl calendar quarterback
and drew brees
it usually doesn't work out like that
and so you know i'm just extremely
humbled and grateful for the opportunity
but i also know that it's just not gonna
be given to us in terms of
trying to win it all uh you know we got
we got a chicago bears team we've got a
great defense
um it's a lot of good teams in the
playoffs so we got to lock in these next
three or four weeks and see
you know where the chips fall after that
well i mean at least it was a normal
a straight line uh from week one to week
17 for you emanuel hold on
wait a minute no it's a pandemic you got
covered uh the quarterback broke his
ribs hold on a second
now the lead you know i mean we could go
on and on and on here about this journey
what was the what was the i guess
strangest part for you
in this journey this 17-week season i
think all of it was strange
right i mean truvia i think all of it
was strange just from
just from just the whole year right uh
you finished the super bowl this like
then 30 days later boom like the whole
city the whole country the whole world
is shut down and
then you like are we gonna play football
we're not doing play football you show
up you got to get cold tested every day
this thing gets stuck in your nose every
morning uh
to you know playing games with no with
no fans
traveling on the road being in a hard
bowl in a hotel not being able to see
family um and then you know midway
through the season
everything's starting to go flow you
start to get used to it and then boom
you show up to work and the next
and then they tell you you just tested
positive and you got a quarantine for 14
days and so
it's just been a roller coaster
everything but truthfully um
you know if you would have said okay
this is what you would have to endure
the whole
the whole year like i would have been
like no way but you know just day by day
you just chug along you just keep going
and you keep going and you just see that
that
no matter what's thrown at you you're
able to adjust and so you know i feel
like
you know i feel like i'm speaking to all
of us that you know i'm kind of proud of
the way that we handle it because
you know things could have been way
worse ten times worse but here we are
uh and just from the nfl in general
you know if you would ask me can the nfl
make it through a whole season right i
said ah it's like
been a 30 or 40 chance but we made it
through a whole season and now here's
the here's the postseason
and uh we're we're on the way on our way
to making it through a full season so uh
kudos to the nfl well i think i i when i
had you on emmanuel sanders at the
beginning
of the season if not just on the outset
right before it i asked you if you
thought that you you'd be able to make
it through a full season
on uninterrupted and you you basically
gave the answer that anyone gave i don't
know i don't i i hope so i don't know
and
and here we are after this whole journey
and you know with
very different practice schedules and
then drew brees did break his
ribs and right towards the uh the back
end of the season
but it does appear that you are more
in rhythm with him going into the
playoffs is that an
accurate assessment yeah every time i
see druid i mean every time i look at
him i don't know why it just comes out
but i look at him
every morning i pass on i said man
you're my guy you're my guy
and i it's not too many guys that i
could say
uh that you know like and and that's not
saying that my god but
just the way that you know i feel about
the dude like he's a legend in my eyes
but
you know you see you see the the sean
payton and drew bridge connection and
i've grown up around
i grew up in the south in houston i've
heard about him you know drew brees is a
legend of me but
just drew brees the person like i've
been enjoying just being around him too
and just just the way that he approaches
the game and the way he goes about his
business it's just
it's just been amazing so if you look at
this team
um and that's the reason why i've been
telling people like and i know i got a
biased opinion in terms of
you know sean pay me and coach of the
year but i've just seen this guy
battle through so much from alvin kamara
being out from drew brees breaking his
ribs to
uh making the decision on jameis winston
or tayson hill from
mike tom mike thomas entering his ankle
first game of the year damn they're
missing the entire season and
and just just guys dropping and coving
and all
all the things that he's balanced i just
seen a guy who really just
coached the team no matter who was out
there and was what they what
was able to win games so we've had our
fair share of adversities through this
whole situation but
um yeah i do believe that like we're
prom
um and i don't think we have a choice
but to be ready to play out
here and and the time's not gonna change
so now is the time
and you've been around some offensive
minds to say the least uh
you you went through uh the the previous
super bowl stops and all your other
teams with aryans
uh in pittsburgh obviously kubiak with
denver we just saw you in a super bowl
with kyle shanahan
give me a good sean payton moment you
you just gave us uh about the
overarching view but uh can you get a
little more granular
of a moment where you're like okay this
cat's a little different
you got something on that oh oh oh
sean's different uh full circle um
just just from a play calling standpoint
you got two different champagnes you got
sean payton that
uh throughout the week champagne
throughout the week so
uh i had to get eight kids to get the
500k every morning i walk into work
sean he greets the entire team every
morning he's judging my outfit because i
like to dress
up to go to work right and uh he's
judging my outfit every day he tells me
okay that's a good outfit that's the
outfit okay that's that so
so i get the i get the 500 i get the 500
and he comes to the back of the plane
just
to just to mess with me and he tells me
yeah you got your 500 thousand he goes
don't be wearing those
white pants anymore right so i'm like
he loves just to pick on me but uh but
then you got sean payton
uh during the game and do not talk to
him during the game because he will
flip out on anybody during the game he's
so
locked in he's so prepared he he has his
strategic ways his chest
uh play uh play making calling ways and
he just wants to execute at a high level
and
that's just him and so you know i've
been enjoying uh
enjoying just being around and just
being in his presence and just seeing
uh just how he is just as a head coach
it's been fun to watch
emmanuel sanders some real talk from the
wide receiver the new orleans saints
here on the rich eyes and show i don't
want you to run the risk of uh
incurring the wrath but can you give us
the you know the updates
on uh on michael thomas and alvin kamara
do you think we see full strength
on sunday as we're sitting here in my in
my opinion
uh as far as mike um i
i think that he'll be back just knowing
my personality
and the playoffs i i i i know he'll be
back
and then as far as alvin um
i think i read something that said that
like he he can show up to the game on
sunday and play
and and me knowing you know alvin and me
knowing
sean and just how alvin comes to work
and how smart
alvin is and how good of a leader alvin
is like
alvin's going to be at that game on
sunday i'll be surprised if he's not at
that game on sunday and
as far as like you know i know
everybody's probably saying he's not
going to work out i don't really know
the details i haven't spoken to alvin in
terms of like his health with the whole
culver situation but
i know like if alvin is is is healthy
enough
and he feels good enough like he's gonna
try to make an effort to play in that
game
so well we'll see we'll see how it plays
off that's just my guess like that's no
factual that's just my guess well and
obviously you know the bears are no joke
defensively what's the challenge
emanuel for you and this i think i think
the challenge is just
you know with the with the whole
playoffs going on everybody always feels
like they have to do more they have to
do more right they have to do more
and in some in some aspect you do have
to do a little more but you don't want
that more to turn into anxiety that
you're not
yourself and so i just think that we
just gotta go out and just do us
we got drew brees we got sean payton we
got
michael thomas alvin kamara myself we
got jared cook we got playmakers all you
have to do is execute at a high level we
got a good offensive line
and we just got to execute at a high
level and and do what we do
and i feel like we'll be fine okay and
again i know
um you got this game ahead of you but
you also
or have as i've told you i say it all
the time
you've got a great media career game
ahead of you
as well so if you don't mind i'd like to
place you just a brief bit
into the role of paparazzi for the story
that everybody is talking about the way
that the eagles ended their season
uh and what the talk might be in your
locker room or you're just your two
cents
and what you think the eagles locker
room might be the giants locker room
might be based on
on the way that sunday night football
played out with nate sutfeld being
inserted into a hotly contested game
emmanuel yeah i know a lot of people are
getting their emotions about it and
if i'm a giants fan obviously i'm gonna
be in my emotions by as well but
i mean doug peterson in my opinion like
he could do whatever he can do whatever
he wants you know everybody talks about
you know the jets
uh you know not losing the entire season
uh and not getting you know uh
you know the quarterback from clemson uh
trevor lawrence but
you know for me like i always sit back
and say you got to do what's best for
your team for
for now and for the future and so
whatever whatever doug peterson wanted
to do like i mean
he can do it you know but and of course
people are going to be in their feelings
over and being emotions but at the end
of the day he made that decision because
he's the head coach of that too
and he he obviously like he felt that
that was the best decision for
his team at the moment whether it was
the move up to get drastics i really
don't know the full details of it right
but yeah you know if it was to move up
to get more drastics for future for a
future team to keep building or stacking
and do whatever you got to do
he has to make the hard decisions on a
day-to-day basis
and he felt like that was the right
decision and you got to respect it at
the end of the day well what about the
own
locker room here uh miles sanders again
i know you got your own world in your
own business so you might not know but
he
said today that the decision to bench
hurts
nobody in the locker room liked it he
said nobody and that he's wondering who
made the decision even though the coach
has come out and said it was his
decision
so it sounds like that there needs to be
some reparations within the eagle's own
locker room
right here so that goes back that goes
back and that's why i bring up
jet it goes back to um and when you talk
about a team like everybody
was like like this thing to jet like how
why did they win that game they could
have got trevor lawrence and it's like
do you not understand that sam darnold
is starting at quarterback
so you're going to tell sam darnold
you're going to go in the locker room
and tell
him hey i need you to blow this game
just so we could
draft the quarterback that's going to
come in and replace you like as a team
or as a as as a player in this league
and i understand what miles is coming
from because he's sitting back and
saying
hey look every day i'm putting my i'm
it's sometimes i think i think about it
i'm like dude like it's one shot
i can literally be paralyzed or i can i
can get hurt
really bad and and miles and 10 back is
saying i'm putting it on the line
every game i don't care if we got
something to play or not well i'm
putting it on the line every game to try
to get a win
and try to enjoy a victory and that was
taken away from me and he felt some type
of way about it and i would too
you know but as far as for the head
coach in the organization
and that's where the player and the
organization sometimes
disagrees because they have to think
long term where the player is only
thinking right now because he's thinking
about
about like as he should
about himself right now as well and so
uh business business is personal person
when they made a business decision
emmanuel that's why again you got your
your career ahead of you when you want
to to get to that i don't know if you
saw your teammate from super bowl 50
akeeb talib already
is making a splash in his role with the
paparazzi did you check
i don't know i don't know if you were
playing at the same time where he was
calling
uh the uh i think was cardinals eagles
is a great game did you
have you heard any of his his calls
we always talk about doing media when we
get down playing ball and i see
him making that jump that fast it's
impressive to see and
and i'm i'm happy for him well i'm
concerned if sean payton would comment
on his garb in the same way that i've
heard sean
uh you say commented on yours uh i don't
know if you saw the suit the christmas
suit
from aqib in the booth
nfl's most fashionable team so we got a
little fashion too
well i mean you're going against cam
you're going against camp so i mean that
was
my the most fashionable super bowl in
the history
[Laughter]
[Music]
have a great time getting out there on
the playoff field i hope for your sake
that you go four for four with teams
um played for making the super bowl i
know saints fans hope the same thing as
well
um and and you keep being you let's chat
soon all right appreciate yours
always that's emmanuel sanders at e
sanders underscore 10
on twitter and adam annual sanders on
instagram hey you watched all the way to
the end
thanks for that watch more right here